the coronaviruses hit black Americans
harder than any other group and that's
why the et B et her and B T's Facebook
pages are focusing on this pandemic and
a primetime special I was asked to
anchor tonight and was very honored to
do so
it's called kovat 19 black America's
fight it's produced by B et News in
partnership with CBS News and Facebook B
et by the way is a division of Viacom
CBS this one-hour special will have
interviews about the devastating impact
with the mayors of San Francisco Chicago
and New Orleans you'll also hear from
changemakers in the black community and
White House officials like dr. deborah
birx you've seen her on the front lines
of the response should the alarm have
been sounded earlier on to the black
community I think he raised a very
important question and it gets to how we
communicate with communities and I think
early on the pictures of this virus were
very much early on about a pandemic and
first in the Asia region and then a
pandemic in the European region where
the pictures of the people in the beds
and the pictures of the people on
ventilators were older white members and
communities no one is immune because
when your community sees pictures of
others they think oh that's the virus
for them I lived that with HIV and I
could see everyone saying oh that's only
the virus for that community you know
viruses infect people indiscriminately
of their race indiscriminately of their
age or their sex and I think really we
need to get the message out to every
community particularly our urban
communities and we know our urban
communities are disproportionately
impacted by this this virus because of
the way it's so contagious
disproportionate is a word and Anthony
part of the problem is early on there
was a terrible rumor that black
Americans could not get it so in the
beginning many black people did not take
it seriously and you see interviews with
people in the documentary who are still
holding on to that I'm hoping by the
time this hour is over they will see it
very differently
yeah and it's become I mean as we as
we've been reporting for the last week
or so it's become really severe I mean
at one point in Louisiana seventy
percent of the deaths were after
and Americans did it disproportionately
impacted exactly and the personal
stories as we all know always make the
difference there are some very powerful
personal stories in this documentary
tonight I saw the rough cut last night
looks really good you can seek Ovid 19
black America's fight tonight at 7
o'clock Eastern me too and Pacific time
it's on again be et be et her and BET's
Facebook pages and stay tuned right
after 8:00 p.m. Eastern and Pacific to
see saving ourselves a bt cove at 19
relief effort it's in partnership with
united way to support the communities of
color